hello I'm Megan Harris I'm a data
scientist at the prostate cancer
clinical trials Consortium and I'm also
a generative artist that's here to
introduce you all to generative art and
a different approach to learning data
science but before I do that I have to
say I feel like I'm only standing here
because I decided to stop working 10
months ago now I didn't quit my job or
anything but as you can see here I was
very pregnant and ready to pop I gave
birth to a beautiful baby I went on
maternity leave for 6 months I know that
sounds fake but this also sounds fake
too I actually found time to code on
leave but I had a rule for myself to
only code if it was for fun stuff like
art so by the end of my leave I was
amazed at how coding art like this
helped with the Practical data science
skills I needed when I returned to work
and I'm going to give a tiny glimpse
into how that was possible so quick
disclaimer it's okay if you don't know
how to make generative art it's okay if
you don't even like art and it's totally
okay if you don't know much about data
science My Hope Is that you treat this
talk like a Choose Your Own Adventure
you know just like those old Goosebump
books hopefully I'm not the only old
person in here who remembers those right
they kind of looked like this so whether
you're here for the
art or the data
science or just learning I'm hoping that
there'll be something for you to take
away from this today and AR those
pictures awesome my husband Dre those
characters for me I love
them okay so quick rundown obviously
we're going to talk about what is
generative art I'll go into how we can
make it in r or python I'll go into some
benefits of creating art then we'll
switch gears and quickly talk about what
data science is I'll give give some
examples of how we can gener um how
generative art translates into data
science excuse me and I'll leave you all
with some final thoughts okay so I want
to pose a question to you all you don't
have to answer me out loud but just
think for a second what do you think
generative art is is it opening up a
digital sketch pad and physically
drawing on a screen or creating outputs
with AI art platforms like dolly or
lensa I couldn't find an official
definition for you all that I liked so
I'm making one right here right now
because I can so in this room today
generative artart is defined as artwork
created through a program in any
language or interface as long as a
program executes the generation of the
art it can be considered generative art
now this is vague in general and yes
that's on purpose because I can
guarantee you that there are multiple
definitions of generative art floating
around in this room right now I'm also
going to assume that at least one of you
in here is thinking of AI art we are not
talking about AI art today and I do have
two statements regarding that so while
all AI art is generative art all
generative art is not AI art and while
some generative art is randomly
calculated by the computer some
generative art is intentional and
deliberately calculated by a human now
what do I mean by that well hopefully I
can show you when we talk about how we
can make art in r or python so it's safe
to say we probably have some data people
in here and that some of you have
probably created visualizations with r
or python so if you know how to make
visuals in this manner you are already
so close to making generative art it
really might not be as hard as you think
you just need the data and the ability
to think outside the grid if you will of
your favorite graphical software or
package now I'm going to be real with
y'all for a second I don't have enough
time here to truly explain in depth how
to make complicated art with code I mean
posit Jenny Hadley I got my email I can
help with the workshop next year if
y'all want I'm just saying I'm willing
but for right now all of the code
examples for the art you'll see today is
on this talks GitHub repo so you can all
listen to me attempt to give a crash
course right now but after the dust is
settled and you're back home know that
these resources are available to you
later okay so when first trying to
create art an R python it's helpful to
pick a data visualization tool you're
comfortable with for me that's GG plat 2
at R but you can use whatever language
and Tool you'd like the main point is
that if a tool lets you plot data it
will let you make artart the challenge
comes in when you need to understand the
uh translation of the data into visuals
so without fail whenever I do a talk
like this there's always somebody who
says I don't understand how you get the
data to put into insert your graphical
tool of choice here and I get it it can
be tricky so let's stop for a minute and
imagine that we want to draw a line on a
piece of paper like in the real world so
if someone is able to pick up a pen and
use it we might assume it's easy for
them to draw a single line on a paper
but we can argue that it might be hard
to make a straight line right so let's
say we upgrade to a graph paper instead
now this may be way easier because we
have that visual guide of the grid lines
but if you stop and think where have we
probably seen a grid like this before
possibly in your favorite visualization
tools for me it's ggplot 2 The Grid
lines reminds me of the coordinate
system all GG plots are created on so
knowing this we can set values to every
Mark we make on the paper just like the
coordinate system in your favorite tool
would we have four coordinate points in
this line each with an X and yv value
where we have four values from one to
four on the x- axis and a constant value
of one repeated four times on the y- AIS
to make the straight line now this may
seem overly simple but that's it that's
all it takes to create generative art
the trick here is that you need to
understand the relationship between the
visuals you want the data you need and
the coordinate system you you set so now
let's look at this example in more
detail in
Python so there can be different
approaches to our last example but
here's just one way now don't get too
bogged down in the specifics of the code
we just want to focus on the process
happening here so first we'll load in
those libraries here it's plot N9 for
plotting and pandas for data frame
creation then we can do some prep for
our data here we're just storing values
and objects for the color and size of
our line next the most important step is
creating the data frame here it's a
pandis data frame with X and Y
coordinates and values for the color and
size of the line finally we can feed
this data frame into the set of ggplot
functions at the bottom there to create
the plot and after we print it we get
the image on the right now this was a
simple example so let's step it up a bit
in something I'm comfortable with which
is R so again we're not focusing on the
code per se but we just want to observe
the general relationship going on
between the data and the the visual so
again we start with the packages here we
have GG plot 2 for plotting d r for data
frame creation and art pack which I'll
talk about in the next section and we
need an idea so let's say we'll make a
simple cityscape with a sky a moon and
some buildings so because we want to Sky
on our background we can make the data
for that first so we make a data frame
with numbers that when mapped on the GG
flat will look like horizontal lines
filling the page we also can add in
variables for the color and size of the
lines and when this data frame is
plotted with the Gom segment function
there at the bottom we get this
beautiful gradient on the right next
let's say we want to have a big simple
Moon so again we make another data frame
that only has data for one single point
it has a big numeric value for size and
some color options we then add this data
frame into the plot with the gon Point
function at the bottom and that creates
the image on the right finally we make
one last data frame for some basic
buildings this time the data frame will
have numbers that will plot Chun chunky
vertical lines we can also go a little
spicy and throw in a sample function to
randomize the heights of our buildings
and like all the other layers we tack it
on with a Gom segment function at the
bottom and we get the image on the right
now I know that was really quick but the
main thing I want you to take away from
that is that the concept of translating
data into visuals is the same no matter
how simple or complex a piece is the
hard part is usually the programming or
the math and if you hate math like I do
don't worry it's okay you can still make
art I'm proof but I also hope you all
took note of how intentional a lot of
the process can be while there's some
artists out there that rely heavily on
completely automated systems or
fine-tuning AI uh prompts there are some
of us out here spending hours exploring
and creating art with code in this
manner so now that we all know vaguely
how we can make this in R python let's
get into some benefits now I'm biased I
think there's lots of benefits to make
making art like this but the most
important for me is just how fun and
therapeutic it can be another big one is
just learning though in general and it
got me to thinking about something so I
have this idea that people may learn
better when they're doing something they
enjoy um and if you enjoy creating art
you might learn some things now I'm not
trying to be funny but I can't just
stand up here and say that this is a
proven fact right so the best I can do
is give you personal examples of how
I've benefited from Making art
so one of the most obvious is that of
improved data visualization skills and I
love to use this example so what you're
all looking at is my very first tidy
Tuesday submission I did years ago so
for any of you who don't know tidy
Tuesday is a weekly data Vis challenge
that we have in the r for DS Community
it used to be super popular on Twitter
before it became a hellsite um but this
was my first submission and you couldn't
tell me nothing I was so happy to make
that lollipop chart as I should have bit
yes exactly
clap but this was my work only two
months after creating generative art and
this was my most recent tidy Tuesday I
did this year so thank you obviously I
developed knowledge of how to make
things more aesthetically pleasing and
how to hack my tool of choice for some
cool results so there are some more
abstract benefits as well like
mathematical and logical reasoning like
imagine how pissed I was when I found
out math was involved to make art man it
sucks but the truth is is that art can
require you to know about patterns
numeric sequences and just general logic
and logic like that is what makes it
possible to go from a grid of points
like this to a grid with skipped
patterns like this to a finished piece
of art like this without having to
manually create the data for every
single Pixel shown
here so there are also some unexpected
benefits as well so one of that being
the community making generative art gave
me another reason to interact with
people and just share what I was doing
and funny enough in this tweet I'm not
calling it whatever it is it's a tweet
when I when I made this tweet last year
I was talking with others about how I
wanted to create an art package but I
was admitting that I was afraid to
because I didn't have a formal developer
background and I didn't feel smart
enough which is now hilarious to me
because another unexpected benefit was
that of package the development so yes I
made my first ever package called the
art pack thank
you it's an Artistry toolkit that's in
early development but as of 3 weeks ago
it is now officially on cray so you can
go and use it it's awesome but I want to
say here that the benefit is not so much
the package itself but just the courage
to learn package development I had a
mental block with doing package
development until I changed the
motivation behind why I was doing it
it's something that I loved okay so now
that I've gushed about how much I love
and benefited from generative art let's
switch gears and quickly remind
ourselves of what data science is I'm
not going to spend too long on this so
data science is a field that uses
statistics Computing methods processes
to extract or derive knowledge and
insights from data honestly all that to
say we're just going to focus on the
coding and programming part of it maybe
a little bit more abstract whatever but
this is just what we're talking about
okay so now that we're all on the same
page about what data science is let's
get into some examples now I have tons
of examples but I'll only focus on three
main Concepts so how this will work is
I'll present the concept first and then
I'll give an example of its use in an
art scenario I had on maternity leave
and a data science scenario I had when I
returned to work so the first concept I
want to bring to you all is iteration so
mastering this in art and data science
can be a huge feat because it's an
important Concept in both Fields there's
so many scenarios where we just want to
do the same thing over and over I don't
think we can deny that iteration really
tends to take people into that next
level of skill because it allows you to
do so much with less so while on
maternity leave I had a task where I
wanted to create lots of copies of a
shape but I wanted each shape to have a
different color a different size and a
different position on the coordinate
system then back at work I wanted to
summarize label and save multiple
process data sets all at once so these
scenarios look a little different but
these are actually both just problems of
iteration so the approach for both the
scenarios is just to isolate the problem
so in the art scenario isolation looked
like figuring out the data like how the
hell do I make that little finger shape
or whatever that was in the data science
scenario hopefully your data is clean
and good so isolation would just more
look like getting your processes to run
on at least one data frame at least once
without any issues so the solution
across the scenarios is the same as well
simply use your preferred method of
iteration to create a workflow once
you've isolated the problem the
challenge is to successfully introduce
iteration now I will point out that my
preferred method um is using perr
functions in R but whether you're using
per and R or for loops and python all
that matters is that you're doing what
you need to in a way that works for you
okay so if we're doing iterations
naturally what comes next is development
so learning and honing in on development
skills can take you to new levels in
generative art this promotes robust
workflows and more complex operations in
data science it does the same but it's
invaluable because it allows you to take
more advantage of the open- source
Paradigm that we have within our
community by creating programs for not
only yourself but for others as
well so while I'm attorney leave I
needed to create a function that spits
out a color palette based on input
choices and back at work I wanted to
create a function that left joined a
table of existing data to another data
frame so these are two different things
but the process for tackling both is
very similar in the art scenario I just
wanted to reduce that code bloat so just
stop copying and pasting things over and
over and in the data science scenario I
just needed to make a new function that
worked because one that we had just like
stopped working as intended so the
approach again is the same to isolate
how do we handle the input of the
function how are things moving through
it and what's coming out so no matter
the scenario whether it's art or data
science you have to go through an
itative process process of debugging and
development to try to create a function
that is hopefully efficient and runs as
intended so again yes that solution is
the same so just hopefully use your
working function lot lots of hopefully
here so whether you're doing artter data
science or using r or python the goal of
creating functions and doing development
is the same we just wish to do a
specific task and an isolated
environment for a consistent output also
creating functions is really like the
Gateway way into a slippery slope of
other crucial development things like
unit testing package maintenance but I
don't have enough time for that so the
last concept I want to bring to you all
is communication so honestly like I
think it's debatable if you need
communication for art I mean like if
you're explaining art methods or
collabor collaborating with others words
Megan I'm sure but for data science nah
fam don't get it twisted you need to
communicate or else it is it won't be
good if you don't know how to
communicate so even though it's not
required for art I did get the practice
to scale out a bit on maternity leave so
on maternity leave I needed help
developing unit test Suites for art
functions in my package and back at work
I needed to perform a data request for a
stakeholder so comparing these scenarios
are interesting because in the art
scenario I am the subject matter expert
that needs programming help and in the
data science scenario I am the
programmer that helps the subject matter
expert by giving them data so both of
these scenarios required communicating
in different ways but they both had that
same need of getting everyone on the
same page so as you might have guessed
the approach is the same between both
scenarios to just identify what matters
so this meant asking myself in the art
scenario what am I functionally trying
to do without the context of the art and
in the data science scenario this meant
asking myself what external context or
details about the data am I missing so
the solution again is to just take the
right course of action to get the
desired result result so in the art
scenario after I took that art context
out of my question I identified what I
wanted to do programmatically and this
was actually the perfect opportunity for
me to practice making represses or
reproducible examples and I did so with
the reprex package available in R and
for the data science scenario I will say
if you're tasked with completing a
request and you're getting too bogged
down in the programming it's a it's a
good idea to stop and ask yourself if
you are missing any external context or
info and if so step away from the
console and go talk to your subject
matter expert I know that sounds scary
but like we got to we got to do it okay
so I just rushed you all that I do want
to leave you all with some final
thoughts so this was a tiny introduction
into the concept of just one type of
generative art this was personal
generative art was my motivation to
learn and do more doing something I
loved made programming and data science
digestible for me so for those of you
interested in generative art I hope this
talk gives you the push to open up your
favorite IDE and try it out for those of
you that are not interested I encourage
you all to consider integrating a hobby
or interest into your learning Journeys
managers and leads at work could you
make room in your team scheduling to
allow for personal development that
looks like this are you willing to let
go of the belief that learning only
looks like courses or textbooks
regardless of what you do after this
talk I want you to think about how
different learning approaches may work
for you
if you're currently having trouble
understanding something try to embrace
learning in a low stress environment
fueled only by your interests it may be
hard but try to let go of the notion
that data science or programming can
only be for profit or practical insights
remember that we can conquer these
beautiful but abstract challenges by
transforming them into passions that we
love and if you're struggling with that
fact that's okay just give it some time
and remember that it's all about
perspective thank
[Applause]
you all
right